auf jeden fall haben wir jetzt hier die
letzten tage bei mir zuhause gestrichen
und die haben streichen sieht man
irgendwelche alten sachen an die auch
mal dreckig werden können und so und ich
habe halt eine hose angezogen
die in loch im schritt hat und dann habe
ich die ist jetzt auch dreckig geworden
farbe und noch mehr da kommt scheiß
drauf und irgendwann beta auf die idee
gekommen war auch plattform scheint
bilder auf die idee gekommen mir eine
hot pants daraus zu schneiden und dann
nehme ich so die diese sei scharfe
schere mit der man diesem diesen maler
teppich zuschneidet baby und schneidet
er so geradezu die hosenbeine ablauf
einer rutschig ablöschen reicht mir in
meine pulsader
servus sg zh und herzlich willkommen zu
einer dragon skate challenge metal metal
gegen krankhafter richtig machen best of
five wird zuerst da gewonnen hat hat
gewonnen
echt klasse
aber ich war aber das klappt war das
knapp weiter weil ich fast direkt am
anfang auch bekannt alter bin ich raus
und normal
ich bin eben gerade drei mal am anfang
fast abgepackt mein vorteil ist dass ich
nie drin war ja fakt das hat leider
nicht gereicht euro alter ist es knapp
wenn allerdings auf der arzt ich bin auf
platz einzelspringen in die lage bei
einem scheiß normalen job
ich bin einfach sein
du hast eben was mich einfach zu weit
gesprungen ich bin einfach in die
landschaft und fonds mit absolute alters
wieder gefallen nein aber okay diese
habe ihr schon mal gewonnen
weiter gekommen als das man nur nutzt
den alter wenn wir beide die ersten
beiden sind ja geht die wahl anfang hat
schon gut meter gemacht und das
wichtigste das am anfang bekommt die
anfangs so sachen kann ich auch immer
ganz vorbei ist einfach und ich weiß was
richtig geübt
nein allein schon verpasst sturm muss
nicht ja lässt der straight edge cache
pro kern stecken falls ihr bock auf
dragon escape habt im allgemeinen jack
ma sturm waffel lp heißt denn youtube
link oder verstören wir loben eingeben
so ganz so wie die bavaria main sowie
die waffe nur mit el hinten dran
er ist echt gut also im job muss man
sagen und auch im pvp nicht der
schlechteste also stark ja das glaube
ich dollar sowie games auf
ich glaube auf unter 90 auf jeden fall
max ist dann vielleicht zu 105 oder so
also auf jeden fall coole typen abdecken
niveau gehabt und ich würde sagen wir
jetzt noch einen kurzen cut wieder
bislang so da sind wir runde nummer zwei
steht 1 0 für mich wir legen los ab das
geht aus 31 max hat ein kuchen im mund
und keinen penis weil die sich wundern
warum er nuschelt
okay aber ich habe mich schon wieder
eingeholt also relativ ich sehe ich bin
ständig was komplett ist mein blick gott
zumindest bemüht heuer gleich nachricht
ist jetzt schon die türen mexiko fall
der mauer steht für brot wechsel auf
jeden fall der also kuranyi der dragon
estatepro ich sag's eigentlich auch
nicht oft aber hey ich wundere mich echt
also ist bisher noch kein verheerende
leck gekommen vom jump teil echt lustig
weil diese passage dann manchmal ein
bisschen - sekunden sowie - geld einfach
super vip jetzt hast du jetzt küste ab
schaut einfach mal die kommentare auf
pop ist super lüthi kennt kommt da ist
dem in italien glauben tun dann hilft
euch bestimmt an den gläubigen super
super richie schneller wie den wind in
die ganzen dragons cap fonds können auch
hier oben ein
die maus herumreißen und ohne auftritt
zu spenden
ach verdammt werden schon ach nein ach
mist aber egal die runde trotzdem ich 20
eingebüßt
ja es kann ich dafür aber wir sehen auf
dem vergleicht was haben jetzt sagen
kann noch aus wir sehen uns nach einem
kurzen kampf wieder wies gleich leute so
dass wir wieder runter nummer drei und
wenn jetzt gewinne habe ich drei zu null
gegen max rasiert und ich würde sagen
wenn ihr bock auf sowas hab da könnte
man solche und einfach mal mit
wetteinsatz machen
das heißt der verlierer muss irgendwas
nerviges dummes schlimmes peinliches
machen jegliches vielleicht auch ist so
ja leute geben die so was machen so wird
ansetzen
zudem gehört natürlich nicht jetzt auch
nicht versteckt im auge oder doch mal
einer den zimbel sprung gemacht
nicht schlecht
simple zombie als ob doch ich kenne
oh nein habe ich diese aufgabe aber so
acht und damit sogar zwei mexikaner ist
ganz weit vorne
wieso brenne ich auf einmal da hab ich
noch nie gebrannt
da fragt nein ich bin ein lappen alter
ein nein auch nein ich hab ja ich habe
glaube ich kein doch ich hab noch einen
lieblich hat noch einen tipp habe ich
noch nein ich meine das unterstütze ich
mich verstellt sich nie abwarte ich pack
tätig stück nicht warte warte warte ich
kann s bekannten lass mich lasst mich
doch lasst mich doch spec täten
ja ich war am boden ich kann nicht
warten und verbrannt habe ich ja richtig
was leider nicht die runde david an dich
zwei zu eins stets empfängern zur hits
und kurze geschichte die ich mir um ein
haar abgeschnitten
also die pulsadern aufschnitt geschichte
in der nächsten runde bleibt dran wir
sehen uns gleich wieso da sind wir
wieder in der runde greenscape jetzt
kriegt ihr die geschichte vom kran auf
die ohren und zwar lassen sich das wort
helfen dämlichste so leicht
trainingscamp kann auch nebenbei als
jetzt das war juni das ganze so
positionieren
maxwell du darfst du darfst du hast dich
sagen manche leute nehmen das ernst
doch bitte nicht hier bitte nicht bitte
nicht wohin sie lieber gott alter nicht
dein ernst ich wollte das schon sagen
ich bin direkt unter der hitze kann hier
sein offert laura h verpackt war kein
vertrauen auch vertagt hast du ich bin
ja ja ich weiß auch hinter mir aber
stück ich alter das ist richtig knapp
das ist richtig top es ist 2 zu 1 und
wenn max it stirbt habe ich ja richtig
was glaube ich ändern ist die dragons
change geworden als es bleibt spannend
ist jetzt echt ein herzschlagfinale
wenn er jetzt gewinnt hat er noch eine
chance und ich selber über diesem block
hat tnt ist nervig nein was gekommen ich
wollte die geschichte erzählt aber ich
muss das nächste folge macht oder danach
weiter auch in ein extra noch nach vorne
gesprungen
ich bin also zu weit nach außen gegangen
bei dem lied dabei einfach ein gitter
scheiße alte was für eine aufholjagd als
einfach unentschieden nach 2 0-führung
krass okay die nächste runde entscheidet
sollte es bleibt spannend wie sehr das
gleich wieder ich machen kurzem hat den
20 größten in dieser runde
bis gleich so da sind wir jetzt wieder
ich erzähle ich jetzt meine geschichte
einfach mal vor die hunde
weil ich gleich in der runde erzählen
kann das wird wieder mega spannend
auf jeden fall haben wir jetzt hier die
letzten tage bei mir zuhause gestrichen
und der beim streichen sieht man
irgendwelche alten sachen ein die auch
mal dreckig werden können und so und ich
habe halt eine hose angezogen
die in loch im schritt hat und dann habe
ich die ist auch dreckig geworden farbe
und mediacom scheiß drauf und hab halt
noch ein bisschen größer gemacht und
irgendwann auf die idee gekommen
aber auch dort dürfen scheint bilder auf
die idee gekommen mir eine hot pants
daraus zu schneiden und dann nehme ich
so die diese sei scharfe schere mit der
mit der man diese diesen maler teppich
zuschneidet du meinst dann kann ich mir
schwer ich meine cherry cherry und
schneidet er so geradezu die hosenbeine
abnehmen auf alma rutschig abgeneigt mir
immer meine pulsadern kein scheiß genau
da wo die burschen sind schneide ich mir
darüber
der schnitt war locker ich sag mal drei
millimeter tiefen also man hat wirklich
sowas aber achtung es geht los
abgeschlossen wirklich was weiß ist
unter gesetz als irgendwelches komisches
gewebe oder so und ich hab einfach es
hat nicht geblutet irgendwie ich hab
dann direkt segert gar nichts ich hab
dann brauch ich habe dann direkt im
pflaster drüber gemacht
ja ja ja ja ja meine runde meine runde
und der ziemlich provinziell einfach
nicht bei minecraft zu select also mein
plex keine ahnung oder warum sonst auf
jeden fall funktioniert nicht so richtig
als sie da so ein disco platten zu tun
aber als auch gut okay so junge
was mir da sie diese desktopdirect er
die ganze dahin könnte auch glaube ich
mit den ultras oder premium für keine
ahnung media
jetzt kommen diese runde
wir haben die challenge und gewonnen
nein nein ich komme einfach an die wand
und die lava bitte nicht auszubrennen
nein ist da hinter mir
durch die mangel der fall hat er nicht
gegeben nein einfach teilstaaten tod ist
so peinlich
na ja auf jeden fall leute lasst eine
positive wertung da wenn euch diese
sache gefällt vielleicht mit einer
bestrafung demnächst oder im einsatz
beschreibt es in die kommentare
es können gerne mal umsetzen und für
seinen check max aus der ist in der
beschreibung ansonsten sehen was beim
nächsten video wieder einen schönen tag
wünsche ich euch ich hoffe ich habe euch
gut unterhalten
das ist meine aufgabe und mach's gut